as we wake up to a new normal today and
life is slowly grinding to a halt in
America's governments from coast to
coast order new restrictions in the
fight against the coronavirus Americans
are buying all the food and supplies
they can find getting ready to stay at
home for a long time business travel and
even family relationships are all
disrupted by this outbreak cities from
New York to Los Angeles are shutting
down schools restaurants and large
gatherings to stop the spread the number
of reported cases of the virus in the
u.s. is now more than 3,700 but the
actual total number could be much higher
and we expect to hear more announcements
from government officials at every level
throughout the day responding to the
newest developments in this crisis but
we begin our coverage of the new normal
in America with molla Lang G at New York
City's Grand Central Terminal normally
bustling at this hour molo good morning
what are you seeing well good morning
Tony as you know Grand Central Station
is typically one of the busiest stations
transit hubs in the country but of
course this is not a typical Monday
morning this is supposed to be the
morning rush but as you can see behind
me not so much this morning schools are
closed businesses are following suit and
more and more people are working from
home which is why Grand Central doesn't
exactly look like Grand Central a not so
familiar sight on Bourbon Street late
night fun coming to a halt by New
Orleans police enforcing the city's new
ban on large gatherings but it's large
gatherings converging on supermarkets
across the country causing shelves to go
empty and even hour-long waits at the
stores days demo video ends no more
toilet paper no more water
president Trump urged calm after holding
a call with major retail and grocery
executives you don't have to buy so much
take it easy just relax across the
country services that millions of
Americans rely on are shutting down
including restaurants gyms and bars
other states are following similar
measures including Washington State
Massachusetts Ohio Illinois and New York
it is quite clear that this crisis is
growing intensely after days of mounting
pressure New York City Mayor Bill de
Blasio announced the nation's largest
public school system with clothes
for at least a month possibly the rest
of the school year impacting more than a
million children here in California
governor Gavin Newsom is in acting
aggressive measures to protect the
state's most vulnerable we are calling
for the isolation home isolation of all
of those 65 years and older and those
with chronic conditions though much of
the country is being told to distance
themselves doctors and nurses are on the
front lines an emergency doctor in
hard-hit Kirkland Washington is in
critical condition after catching the
virus
Michael Marin is president and CEO of
Holy Name Medical Center in Teaneck New
Jersey where all 40,000 residents have
been asked to self quarantine it's part
of why we're burning through it at the
rate of about 700 to a thousand and 95
mass a day because we want to keep our
personnel safe the nation's top
infectious disease expert is not ruling
out a national lockdown Americans should
be prepared that they're gonna have to
hunker down a significantly more than we
as a country are doing more and more
businesses continue to shudder ski
resorts across the country are following
the lead of the cruise ship industry and
shutting down their operations and in
Las Vegas MGM announced the temporary
shutdown of its hotels and casinos
effective tomorrow Anthony all right
mola thank you